dude then guess what what i got my first
traffic ticket ever oh my first time
ever being pulled off speeding ever
you're a goody two shoes i'm like 22
shoes you are a [ __ ]
goody good guy you don't drive fast i
don't do it i drive faster my car uses
brand dude oh
uh florida west palm beach dude we're
trying to go down lamborghini
yeah he was just driving and i was like
that speed is scary driving like you
stole it you're
you're a very unique guy i mean it's
terrifying
yeah yeah so would you get to think
about speeding no he said i was on my
cell phone
that makes sense but i wasn't why would
i okay
listen when are you were you for a
second maybe could you text me on the
way to the gym you said five minutes out
no i didn't yeah i know i talked it okay
yeah but that but
were you talking he saw it no i wasn't
doing anything so i made it up and then
because white made it up white mike was
sitting next to me the cop made it up
well i don't know but i i know i wasn't
on my phone
um he was a [ __ ]
yeah he pulled over gave me a ticket oh
you didn't get to take it sometimes they
watch you though they yeah
you so you don't you can like when i'm
in the carpool lane i'll see cops
the drive up and then they'll look at
you to see if you're on a cell phone and
keep going
they look in the windows now it's the
only the the bike cops you know what i'm
saying that's
real close to your window and to see if
you're on your cell and keep going but
what else so many people on their side
like how many people i saw one [ __ ] i
saw one [ __ ]
on the 405. doing her makeup taxing
not and not in
traffic it's your living room and like
what the [ __ ] yeah no it was weird
because i just had turned the corner
because i was looking at
there's a guy dressed as the joker on
hollywood boulevard because i was on
soundcloud
and then uh i'm at a stoplight and you
know it's me and my friends in the car
and then
he was like pull over and i was like
okay i don't know what the hell went on
i was like because we thought it was
like uh me turning on
uh red but i was like that light was it
you and two white guys it was me
my boy toby from h2o and white mike and
toby's son white mike i caught token
white mike token white white i gave him
that dick
and uh but like when he pulled up
he was like uh lift up those cans and it
was that you know that liquid death
yeah that i drink well it looks like a
beer can sure does and i said oh no this
is water
and then he was like i'll pull you over
for illegal cell phone use and i was
like
what that's what i was like sometimes
there's guys quota can they yeah
for sure can we can they think oh yeah
they've got us yeah
yeah yeah they have to do write a
certain amount of tickets oh
what yeah but if they meet quote
that's what i'm saying thank you he was
giving me this long speech about stuff
when he goes i know you probably have a
habit
of uh using using uh texting while
driving i was like
what i have a habit i was like it was
just i like this guy
my buddy was that i like where this guy
is that was cool with him like you mean
my neighbor was a motorcycle cop and
when i lived in marina del rey
and i see him come home and i just see
him walking he had a little baby
his wife his wife would kiss him on the
head he got like this kiss and brother
and he'd just take his guitar
and just sit there and just be like ding
ding ding
just trying to come back and i was like
how are you doing he goes just want to
blow my brains out every time i'm done
because the negative [ __ ] you get all
day long [ __ ] you
well he was he was being a little stupid
even worse now it's even worse now oh
yeah they're not they're on
edge dude yeah yeah see how high violent
crime is now so
but also i don't i mean i was just being
nice to the dude and like yeah i think
you know
whatever then he was you know cool eased
up or whatever
like yeah lined up but cops always say
you're not gonna talk me out of a ticket
but you can talk yourself into a tank
for sure yeah i was
yeah i got pulled over going fast as
[ __ ] in my porsche during covid when
there's no one on the road he pulls me
over he goes
jesus man how fast thing go i go i know
right how can i not
i said dude there's nobody on the road
oh wait there's no one on the right
you're gonna say and he started laughing
yeah how much horsepower is there right
get out of here later dude that's
awesome so that's what scared me when
you were driving that lambo i was like
what if someone like
is you know casually walking out that's
a risk i mean it was it was granted it
was like one of them i've already talked
to we were going away
ever almost every ticket just because i
[ __ ] around like this i
remember my prius and i'm doing i don't
know what the [ __ ] i was doing
guy goes pulls me over and he goes uh i
go
officer how fast was that going because
he's doing 65 and a 35
you know i'm about to get the ticket on
my life and i go yeah i go
here's the problem you see how it has an
eco and it has a sport button
i wasn't in the support button i saw the
road
she was open
i had to take her you're playing and i
go like this you don't know what it's
like to be behind
the red ram it was a red yeah
so [ __ ] hard and i go and i drive
like this and i made it i go see those
horns he was [ __ ] [ __ ] he goes
dude you just made my day i go it's not
my fault she's got a mind of her own
like i go
don't be surprised if i peel out i
remember when i first
had that red red maroon prius it hurt
your feelings
yeah that's right and i used to park it
illegally i [ __ ] park it
illegally and then the guy no one would
do [ __ ]
the guy was good at me give me a ticket
i was with anthony and some other my
friends
and i'd like to go before you give me a
ticket couple things you should know
number one that's barcelona red yeah i
got this
because barcelona i go yeah and as a
result
i'll park where i want and i will
continue to cool man
no he was cool he's like what the cop
was telling me about the cell phone
stuff is that like
i guess on july 1st there's a lot like
so if you get caught with your cell
phone get pulled over blah blah that can
go on your driving record good
good wait wait wait wait they got to
make it if you're caught oh you're
caught with yourself
good they should a lot of people die i
think they said they said more accidents
happen from
the cell phones driving than anything
yes yeah if you're worried about covet
you should also be worried about [ __ ]
cell phone but also yeah my screen tells
me you can tell me what people's uh yeah
it wasn't on my phone
i mean whatever but even if it's a
screen that means you're looking at it
no no no no no
my screen on my car see i i'm still
looking
i was at a red light every time you had
a red light
that was when that happened well i'm
sure who are you and i'm sure you're
here
i'm sure yeah chappelle's a bit of a
goody two shoes though now obviously i
believe
most of the definitely text and driving
no no i believe you're a little goody
two shoes bro
when i'm normally in my car i throw my
phone in the back
see you're i believe that i believe
you're a you're a
straight up he's a square you're an rs
fight you're an rf you're a rule fighter
i don't want to do that you do follow
rules you get your hands full yeah he
follows rules